so there are people out there that if
you run into they can't help themselves
well tell you about their sports team
their local charity their church they go
to the sports team they believe in their
politics their views and all this other
stuff if you're around me I want you to
start a business that's what I want you
to do I just want to help you start a
business so today in this video I'm
going to talk to you about how you can
start a business for less than five
hundred dollars and I'm going to
simplify to you in a way that probably
it's never been simple but simplify like
this before so let's get right into it
there's really six things you can do to
exchange what you're providing to the
consumer the customer for money and
profits to you number one you're
providing a service for me number two
you're giving me advice because you're
an expert your expertise is what I'm
paying for number three you're selling
me a product you bought it for five
bucks you sell it for twenty number four
you educate me
number five you've given me an
experience number six you're
entertaining me all of those six things
you and I spend money on every single
day all of those six things are things
you can figure out a way to start making
money for yourself so now let's start
off with services mobile auto detailing
this is the easiest thing to start off
with go get a couple of the equipment
for less than five hundred dollars and
start servicing cars in your community
start with $20 $25 $30 I don't want to
go to a car wash people don't want to go
to a car wash once you get a trail going
next thing you know there's a ton of
things you could be doing with that
where your cleaning three cars for one
house next-door neighbors to say can you
come by and do three cars what are you
charging can you combine do this can you
combine then you come to a business
building then you call the business
management the buildings are manager and
you say hey I'd like the service cars
and for the people in the building I'll
give free a you know service to you and
your employees as the manager team and
I'll get 20% discount for all the
tenants there and we'll be cool service
for you no problem then you got ten
buildings then you got twenty buildings
then you got twenty people cleaning cars
in all these different places now you're
making three four five six seven eight
ten thousand dollars a month because you
started mobile detailing business dog
walker babysitting being a chef if I
knew how to cook I don't know how to
cook but if I know how to cook I would
figure out a way I remember I went to a
restaurant one time in Kentucky it's
called six
Magnolia if you search 610 Magnolia and
we walk into this place I took ten of
our friends to Bill ended up being
$3,300 right after Kentucky Derby we
went to this place that's when I met
Arnold Palmer just a real cool place I
said how did this place get started he
said he was a guy that he cooked so well
that everybody in the community wanted
him to cook for him so he said every
Friday night he cooked in his house but
it was $200 and it was a seven-course
meal and people had no problem paying
for it so ten people would pay for it so
$2,000 every Friday night then he took a
house and he turned the house into a
restaurant called 610 Magnolia that's
the address to the restaurant that's the
name of the restaurant just because
people like this cooking you turn into a
business
another one is landscaping another one
is running errands and then let's get to
some of these other things here which by
the way I want you to know that this
video sponsored you by Fiverr at this
point I think many people know my
relationship with Fiverr and how much of
a believer I am in fiber and so
voiceover voice acting voice
impersonation you may need a you may
know how to do voiceovers in different
languages go on Fiverr people will pay
you 20 30 40 bucks just to do your voice
for them I've paid in multiple different
times to have a British accent to have a
different type of an accent you got a
voiceovers for commercials to do maybe
you know how to do editing writing
editing video editing
put yourself on Fiverr maybe you know
how to design websites and you know how
to produce them for yourself again go on
Fiverr and put yourself out there as a
talent to provide your services for
other people now if you're watching this
right now you're saying I want to start
my own business but I need a website go
on fiber comm have somebody build a
website for you if it's $100 $200 $50 if
you use the code the discount code Pat
bet they'll give you 20% discount so
expense $600
you'll get $120 disc and spend $100 get
a $20 discount as long as you use the
coupon code path bet you'll get a 20%
discount so website logos coaching kids
I was at a baseball game yesterday for
my kid
and this guy next to me who played a
football to pay professional on the
football side
said so what is what are there some
programs here for baseball he says oh my
gosh
coaching six-year-olds and teaching them
how to swing and catch the ball has
become a business your locally and so
what kind of a business he says there
are people that code that played college
baseball or having kids parents are
having their kids be coached by this
guy's fifty dollars per 30 at 30-minute
session I said what yes fifty dollars
they're getting there it's a picture
they're going to capture position their
throne involved they're doing all this
other stuff because somebody else
doesn't have the time to do it there's
money then the massage massage is just
you can do massage services to offices I
would bring people to my office and they
would give massages to 20 people at a
time fifty dollars a pop that's a
thousand dollars I mean that's a pretty
nice amount of money to be made there's
money here if you know how to massage
next expertise go get your notary
license people need to notarize stuff
and they need fingerprint signatures $10
a pop $15 a pop and then they pay for
the gas as well get your real estate
license get your insurance license this
is a route I took I want to got my
insurance license I don't have a four
year I don't have a two-year degree this
became my degree I got insurance and
security theory 766 31:26 I started
selling and I became an expert in
investments I became an expert in
insurance and I got paid for by
insurance companies for doing that
security guard you're a big guy you know
how to fight you took boxing you know
martial art you want to figure out a way
to go become a security guard go do it
and I find some of your other peers on
you maybe you can start a security guard
business personal trainer translate you
speak other languages you know how to
translate for people there's a very very
very big need for this I have a lady
that I met at heart which is local right
here in East Plano
she started a business simply for
translating her business that's
thirty-five million dollars per year
just to translate businesses just to
translate for hospitals that don't know
how to speak to a certain patient when
they're doing they your questionnaire on
their help she has all the different
languages with people that are
translating for them from their house
next sale sell t-shirts sell flowers so
fidget spinners nowadays everybody wants
to buy that I remember back in the days
in 2000 and in 2000 a product that come
out called clipping talk back in the
days
there was no speakerphone and there was
no Bluetooth on the phone so clipping
top will link to radio station I think
88.7 and you would clip it on your phone
and anybody who would call you this
sound would come out of the speakers and
you would speak to them as if it's
bluetooth so it was it was a ghetto type
of Bluetooth back in the days but I
would buy it for five dollars and I sell
it for twenty bucks a pop I can't tell
you how many of them I sold during the
time while I was getting into the
securities industry shoes has pick a
product by divide wholesale selling
retail educate teaching your language
you may know certain instruments you're
teaching me I want to learn you may know
how to teach kids how to read and write
tutoring it's a big business then you
got an online tutorial a personal
defense there's a lot of people nowadays
I want to learn personal defense
especially in certain communities what
if you start teaching personal defense
classes and you do it as a group
ten ten people show up you show them
somebody attacks you what you do how you
how you get out of it all this other
stuff there are people that are willing
to pay for this experience
what's the experience give me a fun
experience for boot camp class at 6
o'clock in the morning and it's an
experience
at a local park $20 a class $15 a class
ten people show up you made $150 not
only did you get a workout where you got
empty but I'd also showed up it was fun
running to get all this other stuff
hiking maybe you're somebody that knows
all the hiking trail spots in your area
give me some of those secrets hike it's
hiking training spot and you have all
the equipment let me bring the group and
say hey I'll go with you for three hours
we'll have a great time I'll take you to
a secret spot I know everything in this
area but it's a hundred dollars it's $20
a person it's $30 a person whatever
people are willing to pay for that surf
you know how to surf most people are
afraid of surfing but almost everybody I
know most people want to know how to
surf because it's cool but they're
afraid what if I don't know how to do it
it's embarrassing I'm going to fall you
know how to do give me a fun experience
I'll pay you for it
and last but not least is entertainment
listen you go on YouTube people say man
no one watches these educational videos
because people would much rather laughed
and be educated so guess what turn it
into a business
comedy arts teach people how to paint or
at the same time entertainment draw me
paint me there's people that do this
everywhere
20 bucks of painting 30 bucks are drawn
and people pay forward a dance you know
how to dance there I was in Miami and in
Miami South Beach right off of a1a there
was this a boyfriend/girlfriend that
we're dancing and what they were doing
is in a middle of the strip in the
middle of the strip they were dancing
and they were going to bring in people
to dance and they had a bucket people
drop in $20 $15 $20 $10 $10 and all
night all they did is boys and
girlfriend dance all night Friday from 9
o'clock to 1 o'clock in the morning and
they made 400 bucks can you imagine
dancing all night and you make $400 just
from dancing there are so many ways to
make money YouTube stars singing go sing
out there people will pay for it have to
see these selling people will buy my
bought a CD from a guy who is from
Argentina him and his brother in Santa
Monica they would play the guitar in a
way I've never seen before
I bought the CD from him for 20 bucks I
listened to that CD for a whole year in
my car because he had this one song he
would play would just speak to your
spirit he is not a big-name person no
one knows him but I paid 20 bucks from
that to get a CD and I listened to it
work for Europe magic you know how to do
magic tricks there's many ways to make
money doing magic tricks
people want to be entertained so again
watch all of these things figure out
which one connects to you and then start
a business for yourself and by the way
if you need your banners if you need a
website if you need a logo if you need
any of that stuff go to fiverr.com - RS
go to fiverr.com use the coupon coupon
code tap bed to get a 20% discount with
the services that they offer on
fiverr.com so with that being said you
got any questions comments comment on
the bottom Andrew let me get that pillow
right there brother and if you have not
subscribed to this channel yet be sure
to do so click on the subscribe button
right here and right next to there's a
notification button you'll be one the
first to be notified every time the
videos come out so join the notification
squad take everybody by
you
[Music]